for as long as there's been crime there
have been criminals bragging about those
crimes smartphones record our daily
lives and some of our daily lives
include a whole bunch of crime
hey what's up guys welcome back to
illegal eagle today i stole 50k of
bitcoin and used it to hire a hitman
because it's fun this is why you should
take legal advice from a youtuber
remember to like and subscribe and
always brag about your crimes online and
to the police
and i can't remember who said it but
it's a strange coincidence that as soon
as we all had video cameras in our own
pockets 24 7 ghost disappeared aliens
stopped visiting and police started
shooting unarmed people but while the
phones may be smart the criminals are
still really dumb so today we're going
to cover some of the most stunning
instances where criminals might just
have gotten away with it if it weren't
for those meddling smartphones now
selfies are not just about making dumb
faces with a dream of gaining instagram
influence selfies also have helped bring
dumb criminals to justice like 19 year
old albert wilson who stole a phone took
a selfie and then tattled on himself by
accidentally emailing his own photo to
the victim and here's how it all went
down one fateful saturday night in 2013
albert wilson and five accomplices
surrounded a 16 year old boy in the
bronx ordering the victim to empty his
pockets wilson proceeded to grab the
teen's samsung galaxy s epic smartphone
before fleeing with his fellow thieves
but the mystery of who stole the teen's
phone would not last very long because
shortly after the robbery wilson could
not help but test the photographic
quality of the samsung galaxy by
snapping his selfie but honestly that's
not surprising hey renee how good was
the samsung galaxy s's camera well devin
samsung is actually the perfect camera
for recording your crimes unlike google
which focuses its massive ai powers on
computational photography or apple which
tries to do a little bit of both samsung
has just always been all in on sheer
optical girth just massive and multiple
lenses crafted front and back with
conveniently pre-crushed blacks that's
the color correction term an auto
boosted sat for all your ready-to-social
climbing needs there you have it
criminals if you're going to crime you
definitely use a samsung but what wilson
did not know the phone was set to
automatically upload all photographs to
the teen victim's email account and with
a literal photo id of the teen attacker
in his inbox well the victim immediately
took that selfie to the police wilson
was swiftly arrested and charged with
robbery possession of stolen property
and a controlled substance believed to
be crack cocaine oh oh i'm sorry didn't
you get into the crash did somebody get
addicted
so thanks to wilson's selfie justice was
served now
i know that this is the least important
part of the story but i have to remark
that
wilson has an absolutely terrible selfie
game i mean just look at this travesty i
mean the photo is hazy you can see the
phone's reflection in the glasses and
you know why are you wearing headphones
so honestly uh six out of ten though
bonus points for taking a photo in front
of a sign that says arrest anyway our
next criminal might be even dumber
because he posts a photo of himself
siphoning gas out of a cop car now when
it comes to dealing with high gas prices
there are many ways to lessen the pain
of the pump some opt to take public
transit others have elected to switch to
electric or hybrid vehicles
but one kentucky man decided to engage
in his own amateur oil exploration by
siphoning gas directly from a police
officer's car and then brag about his
crime
on facebook and i'm sure that you can
guess exactly how that turned out so in
2012 a 20 year old kentucky resident
michael baker and his girlfriend
stumbled upon an unattended jenkins
police vehicle and ceasing the
opportunity for some free fuel baker
proceeded to siphon gas from the squad
car and he might have gotten away with
it except baker couldn't resist the urge
to have his girlfriend snap a photo that
showed him not only stealing gas but
also flipping the bird and then he
memorialized it by posting it to
facebook now there's the old proverb
that goes pride cometh before the fall
and also only idiots post to facebook
but this cocky kentuckian was done in by
his own vanity after bragging about his
crimes on facebook the county issued a
warrant for baker's arrest one month
later baker was taken into custody and
charged with misdemeanor theft well he
was just standing there and i thought
it'd be funny take a picture
and
didn't post it on facebook yeah we're
sorry it was just a joke i mean if we
was gonna steal gas we wouldn't put it
nationwide on facebook which we don't
steal anyway but and although the
siphoning photo was removed from his
facebook page baker managed to keep his
380 friends surprised of his latest
legal problems quote just got out of
jail he wrote in one post and in another
post he wrote quote yeah lol i went to
jail over facebook and in response to a
friend who had not seen the image before
it was removed baker assured quote yeah
lol you just have to seen it it was
funny as hell though so i mean do you
apologize to the cops for it
and then moving one state over we have
the tennessee man who attached an apple
watch to his girlfriend's car in order
to try to stalk her now uh apple markets
the apple watch as quote the ultimate
choice for a healthy life now the apple
watch boasts a variety of health and
safety features for its users the apple
watch can track your heart rate track
your workouts can even be used with air
tags track items you might have
misplaced items
like your girlfriend yeah unfortunately
a nashville man decided to use the apple
watch for nefarious purposes to track
his girlfriend's every move and stalk
her with watch's location technology now
thankfully police were able to intervene
before anything dire happened according
to the march 2022 affidavit welch's
girlfriend visited the family service
center a domestic violence shelter to
seek a restraining order against him now
police officers were summoned to the
family safety center after security
informed them of welch's presence but
remember tracking goes both ways when
the police inspected the victim's car
they found an apple watch attached to
the spokes of the car's wheel and
they were able to link that to the
person who was trying to track her but
funny story this is actually very
similar to how i keep track of renee
ritchie at all times i've been using an
apple watch all day every day but then
there's the ohio man who sent in a
selfie of himself to police to replace
the terrible mug shot that they took of
him
these friggin people anyway you know
when most people get a bad picture
whether it's on a driver's license or
for a school photo you know they just
take the loss and hope for a better
picture the next time around but ohio
man donald chip pugh learned the hard
way that when you're on the run from the
law maybe that's not the best time to
contact the police to complain about
your mug shot pablo didn't know it then
but this mug shot was going to cause him
a lie grief down the line unless your
goal is to assist the police with your
capture which of course is exactly what
happened in this particular case in 2016
pugh was scheduled to appear in court
for a pending dui charge in lima ohio
and when pew skipped his hearing local
police posted a mug shot on facebook to
solicit the public's help in tracking
him down quote mr pugh is also currently
a person of interest in several other
cases including for arson and vandalism
now pugh saw his mug shot and was
furious not that the police were trying
to track him down or that he committed
multiple crimes but that his picture had
failed to capture his good side so pugh
took the initiative dressed himself up
in a houndstooth pattern suit not unlike
the one that i'm wearing right now put
on some sunglasses and texted the police
here's a better photo that one is
terrible with an accompanying selfie now
pew was no stranger to the lima police
department having had previous run-ins
that included charges of disorderly
conduct breaking and entering and
domestic violence but this was the first
time that pew had ever reached out to
the police while they had an active
arrest warrant for his arrest
now the lima police uh honored pew's
request uploading his new bug shot to
facebook and writing quote we thank him
for being helpful but now we would
appreciate it if he would come speak to
us at the lpd about his charges now a
smart criminal might lay low to avoid
drawing attention to themselves but this
video is not about smart criminals and
as it turns out pew was not done talking
about what he considered to be a grave
injustice of an unflattering photo so
after pugh's mugshot and selfie began
circulating on the internet he decided
to call into lima's classic rock station
104.9 the eagle to tell his side of the
story now the local station spoke to pew
for its idiot of the day segment and as
it turns out pew had the honor of being
the first idiot to ever be interviewed
on air where you out of getting chip
right now
yeah actually i'm sitting in a bunker
right next to chapel guzman we're trying
to take a tunnel and get to mcdonald's
but sadly pugh's run from the law did
not last very long the next morning pugh
was arrested 800 miles away in century
florida because at heart we all knew
that this ohio man was really a florida
man in ohio
northern florida i mean let's be honest
they're really like angling for that
weird stuff happens here but ladies and
gentlemen there is a happy ending to
this story when pew was arrested in
florida he got to take his mug shot over
again though i have to admit i don't
think that that's much of an improvement
over his first one now sometimes
criminals are incredibly stupid but
sometimes the police are just really
really smart and such was the case when
the fbi actually created a fake
messaging app and then got a whole bunch
of criminals to use the fake encrypted
messaging app because most of the cases
we've talked about today involve
criminals using smartphones to tell on
themselves but when it comes to the more
savvy criminals who are actually trying
not to get caught committing crimes
these folks often turn to encrypted
messaging to cover their tracks and
shield their communications from the
prying eyes of law enforcement that's
because when messages are encrypted it's
nearly impossible for law enforcement to
learn what criminal groups are doing so
when faced with encrypted messaging what
is law enforcement to do well simple
develop their own fake encrypted
messaging app trick criminal
organizations into downloading the fake
app and wait for the incriminating
evidence to just roll in and that was
the work of what was known as operation
trojan shield a successful multi-year
electronic sting operation led by the
fbi in conjunction with the dea
europol the european police agency and
law enforcement groups from 16 other
countries because in 2018 the fbi and
its international partners shut down
phantom secure a canadian-based company
that provided secure communications to
high-level drug traffickers and other
criminal organizations the company would
purchase smartphones wipe them clean of
all traditional functions like texting
internet and gps and then it installed
encrypted email systems that could only
communicate with other phantom secure
phones and if a customer was arrested
phantom secure would destroy all data on
the phone
now after the feds shut down phantom
secure the ceo vincent ramos was then
indicted by a grand jury along with his
colleagues and would eventually plead
guilty to a raft of charges related to
drug trafficking and with phantom secure
gun criminals were in search of a new
encrypted messaging app and that's where
operation trojan shield comes in now at
the beginning of the operation the fbi
recruited an unaimed confidential human
source who had been developing a next
generation secure messaging platform for
the criminal underworld called anon now
the app would only work on specially
modified cell phones similar to those
created by phantom secure but what the
users didn't know the mystery developer
had engineered aenom to secretly forward
law enforcement a copy of every message
that was sent on the platform after
aenom's launch in october 2019 the fbi
convinced a few criminals to tell others
about the phones and soon enough the app
caught on like wildfire in an 18-month
period law enforcement provided nearly
12 000 aenom phones through unsuspecting
middlemen to more than 300 criminal
syndicates in more than 100 countries
and many of the criminals assured each
other that the app was incredibly safe
but rather than being safe police in
real time could read criminals
discussing targeted hits drug shipments
and other crimes with users making no
attempt to hide criminal plots with code
words and between october 2019 and june
2021 authorities collected more than 27
million messages in 45 languages and
armed with this treasure trove of
incriminating data the fbi and its 16
international partners carried out raids
in their respective countries in a 48
hour period 9 000 officers deployed
worldwide to make arrests and searched
more than 700 locations according to the
fbi more than 32 tons of drugs were
seized killjoys along with 250 firearms
and 48 million dollars in cash and more
than 50 secret drug labs were dismantled
including one of the largest clandestine
labs in german history in total
operation trojan shield resulted in 800
arrests including 500 in the 48 hour
period and then finally i feel like i
shouldn't have to tell you this but i'm
going to tell you this anyway
don't livestream your crimes because
many of the people on our list found
themselves in legal trouble because they
shared evidence of crimes after the fact
but in the case of tim gionette better
known as baked alaska this famed online
provocateur has built himself up quite a
rap sheet by live streaming his crimes
in real time this idiot baked alaska is
a far-right internet troll who openly
aligned himself with the white
nationalist gruiper movement even
appearing at the infamous 2017 unite the
right rally in charlottesville at the
time mr alaska went viral for getting
pepper sprayed while marching with a
white supremacist in charlottesville as
he begged people around him to keep live
streaming as he kneeled on the ground
milk dropping down from his face i got
peppers i need milk
i need milk i need milk
[Music]
racist advocacy and promotion of
anti-semitic conspiracy theories caused
him to be banned from a variety of
platforms including twitter youtube
paypal and uber now despite this baked
alaska's live streaming antics only
increased and he often filmed himself
conducting all manner of illegal things
but it reached an apotheosis on january
6 2021 when as you know supporters of
donald trump stormed the us capital in
an effort to prevent the certification
of joe biden's election we're storming
the capital it's a revolution and this
is where baked alaska's live streaming
caused himself and his allies the most
legal trouble to date on january 6 baked
alaska began his hour-long livestream
outside the us capitol before eventually
finding himself inside the building and
interviewing participants yeah we need
to get our boy donald j trump in the
office yeah yeah can we do that real
quick at one point baked alaska turned
to the camera to show his face we are in
the capitol building 1776 will commence
again and despite what looks like
participation in the coup attempt
including shouting anti-semitic and
queuing on dog whistles while urging
others to remain in the building baked
alaska told police officers that he was
a member of the media court documents
also state that baked alaska said on
camera occupy the capitol let's go we
ain't leaving this
you know just your regular everyday
legitimate political discourse now days
after the video was posted baked alaska
was identified and arrested on multiple
counts including unlawful entry violent
entry and disorderly conduct on capitol
grounds but in a spectacular cell phone
for the far right the fbi then used
baked alaska's livestream to
successfully arrest dozens of writers
captured on film including baked alaska
himself
[Music]
[Music]
so the takeaway here is if you're going
to be a racist treasonous dirtbag troll
who tries to overthrow the government
you should definitely live stream it
your friends are going to love it i need
milk i need milk
so the bottom line is you should never
use your phone to document your crimes
but you should definitely use your phone
to get delicious meals delivered
straight to your door with today's
sponsor hellofresh hellofresh is a great
way to eat delicious fresh food while
still being healthy in fact hellofresh
has a whole variety of calorie smart
carb snork pescatarian and veggie
options you can customize it just how
you like hellofresh delivers fresh
quality produce from the farm to your
door in less than a week so you can
savor all the fall flavors right from
your home now i'm a do-it-yourself
person and i have to say i was initially
pretty skeptical about hellofresh i'm a
pretty good cook so i didn't think that
i needed the help but i actually loved
it even for an experienced cook
hellofresh delivers new ingredients and
recipes that i would never try on my own
hellofresh generally keeps everyone's
favorite meals then rotates new ones in
all the time in fact i usually increase
the size of my hello fresh serving so i
can enjoy the leftovers for lunches and
of course everything was delivered
straight to my door so i didn't have to
do any shopping the produce actually
gets to me faster than a grocery store
so it arrives at peak freshness and
flavor and it's also super easy to save
time hellofresh cuts out the meal
planning and prep so that recipes take
only 20 to 30 minutes to cook literally
less time to cook than it would normally
take me to do the shopping itself and
it's also incredibly sustainable since
the ingredients are pre-portioned
there's less prep and food waste the
packaging is almost entirely made from
recyclable or already recycled content
and hellofresh's carbon footprint is
actually 25 lower than those of meals
made from store-bought groceries and of
course it's 72 percent cheaper than
dining at a restaurant so if you'd like
to try hellofresh you can click on the
link below or go to hellofresh.com and
use the code
legaleagle65 for 65 off plus free
shipping yes you can actually get 65 off
plus free shipping by clicking on the
link that's on screen or down in the
description so go to hellofresh.com use
the code legale65 or just click on the
link below plus clicking on that link
really helps out this channel after that
click on this playlist for more illegal
eagle or i'll see you in court